- We don't teach history in schools.
So the fact that we
condense Black history
all in one month when Black history
is American history, it's like we
do ourselves a disservice, not only
for, not only for the legacy of Black
people and what we’ve actually contributed to
this country, but for the perspective
of white people to know, you know,
that this is their history as well.
That the things that were done to
Black people is what is the white legacy.
- [Taylor Rooks:] I'm Taylor Rooks.
And these are conversations about
defining one's relationship to Blackness
and how that defines their America.
OK.
OK, Malcolm.
So I am starting all of these with the
exact same question, which is:
When did you realize that being Black
was different from being white?
- I didn't realize it probably until
the third grade
because I started school at a private
school that was all Black
in the city of Newark, New Jersey.
It was called Chad School.
And I laugh now because I'm like,
it was almost like they were, it was
like an academy for Black Panthers or
something. Like, every day we sung
the Black National Anthem. Every
day was Black History Month.
We called everybody brother, sister.
Um, that's how we addressed our teachers.
And it was like, they just
taught you so much about
your, you know, your heritage, like,
having pride in being Black and,
like, how to work as a community.
And so I was there from pre-K until second
grade, and then in third grade, I moved to
Piscataway, New Jersey, where I spent the
rest of my time and went to public school.
And it was, you know, a stark difference, all the way
from just not seeing any Black teachers
in front of you to the curriculum,
you know, being totally different to
even, like I said, the National Anthem
and what you saw, what you sung
kind of every day—those routines and
rituals were totally different.
And I think that representation,
um, that you usually, that I was
used to seeing was no longer there.
And I think that's kind of when I began
to see the difference between,
you know, something that I was, like, so
proud of and grew up kind of honoring,
going into a different situation and
seeing it not necessarily be held to that same regard.
- And I would say most Black people probably
did not have that experience, you know,
when they're younger being surrounded
by Black people, but also Blackness.
But I do want to talk about
why there is a need for exclusively
Black spaces, because I think that
some white people might hear this and
say, “Well, that's dividing us, having
you at a school that is only with Black
people.” But, and it's the same thing I say
when I would hear white people say
that the TV show Blackish was racist.
It's that Blackish actually isn't racist,
and you guys have plenty of
programs that are whitish.
They're just called things like
Friends or Seinfeld or Sex and the City.
- Right. Right.
- And since the world has been so
catered to white people and what white
people like to consume, you don't need
the things to explicitly be called
Black because everything is white.
So you don't have to name it as white.
- I mean, even think about like, uh, when we
talk about, when we name different groups of people
in America, we say African American.
We say Asian American, Latin American,
all of these different types of American.
But when we talk about white, the
white people, it’s just American because
we've always kind of had that idea
that white is synonymous with American.
- Yeah.
Like, white needs no hyphen.
- Right.
- They need no hyphen in their identity.
And I think, you know,
especially for
Black people,
we oftentimes don't have
a lot of those safe
spaces. You know, when you look
at, even, even from like a commerce
or business standpoint, you go to
almost every major city in the country,
you'll have a Chinatown, you'll
have a Little Italy, you'll have
these pockets where different, you
know ethnicities, you know, have
these spaces that they can retreat to.
They do business with each other, and it's
not exclusive, you know? It's not like
people can't come into those communities.
But now those are their spaces.
And I feel like Black people don't
really have those kind of spaces.
And so I think it's important
for us to create them.
I know it was important for
me to even, like, start my
education in a space like that.
You know, and I have friends that
I've, you know, known since kindergarten,
and all of us kind of have that
same now framework and perspective on
our Blackness, on our history and culture.
And we see the difference between us and
our peers who had different experiences.
- Yeah.
And going off that, I don't remember
the exact article and the ins and
outs of it, but it was discussing
how a lot of other, like, races and
ethnicities have things like Chinatown,
Little Italy and things like that.
But
the Black neighborhoods and the
Black communities don't have those
because the dollar circulates
one day and leaves the next day.
Whereas in those other smaller
communities, like Chinatown
and Little Italy, the dollar
stays there for, like, a year.
- Well, we used to have those
things, and that's, that's the
one thing that I had to learn.
Cuz I asked that same question.
Why don't we have, like, like, our neighborhood is the hood.
Like, we don’t own anything in it.
Like, we, if the dollar leaves
the neighborhood, you know, why
can't we build these things?
And, and that's when my family
kind of taught me about Black Wall
Street in Tulsa, Oklahoma, in 1921
and other communities like it.
And a lot of those communities during
the Jim Crow South, where they
didn't really have much—nothing near
the freedoms that we have today—
they were still building wealth.
They were building their own
businesses, huge communities where
literally they had all classes of
people from wealthy Black folks all
the way down to the working class.
And they kept that, that
money into their communities.
And unfortunately, almost all of
those neighborhoods met the same
fate. And it was either burned down or
violently dispossessed from Black
people and really never recovered.
And so, you know, that's, that's
one of those things when we look at,
um, by today's context, we like, “Damn,
why don't Black people have these spaces?”
Like, we, you almost, you’ll think that
we are doing something to, you know,
that, or we aren't doing something
like everybody else when really, if you
know our history, we've done this
probably better than anybody else
and have just had it destroyed.
And then, you know, then you had all of
the legislation and other things that
were put in place to keep it that way.
And now here we are in 2020,
trying to figure out how to
recreate those types of spaces.
- Yeah. And I mean, I think, and this
is a thing me and you talk often.
This is a thing that we have discussed is
the way that we tell stories is important,
and the way that you start stories.
Because a lot of people had never
heard of Black Wall Street until,
like, Russell Westbrook said he
wanted to do a documentary on it.
And some people were like, “What is that?”
And it's because if you tell the
story of Black people starting
with simply, like, oppression, right?
Or if you tell a story of Black
people starting with now, you're
gonna miss the context of the
things that have happened to us
that disabled us from doing many of the
things that we should be doing every day.
- Yeah.
- And that takes away,
I think it skews the entire story.
And I think in a lot of ways has skewed
the way people view Black people.
- Yeah.
I think that's why we've arrived now,
like, and a lot of white people
struggle with the idea of racism
because we've, we've painted the
picture of racism to be water hoses and
dogs and calling somebody the N-word,
and that's not the
only form of racism.
You know,
and there are so many
other systems that were put in
place that were, that were tied and
synonymous to racism back in the day.
But once we, you know, lost our stomach for
lynchings and hoses and dogs,
those systems still stayed in place.
And I think
we don't teach history in schools.
So the fact that we condense Black
History all in one month when Black
history is American history, it's
like we do ourselves a disservice,
not only for, not only for the
legacy of Black people and what we’ve
actually contributed to this country,
but for the perspective of white
people to know, you know, that
this is their history as well,
that the things that were done to Black people
is, is the white legacy, like, as
much as we don't like to talk about it.
And even, even, you know, places
like Tulsa, Oklahoma, the reason a lot
of people don't know about it is because
even the state of Oklahoma didn't even
recognize the incident until 2011.
And so it's a lot of these things are
not, from a historical point, not things
that we want to push forward as a country.
And so they’re oftentimes swept under
the rug, and we try to have that
reconciliation without really
arriving on a common truth.
And so we’re constantly, like, you know,
confused. White people are like, “I'm not
racist and I don't understand racism.”
And it's because they haven't
been taught about how racist systems
work or how things can be skewed
or the history, and Black people,
we know it because we feel it, but
oftentimes we don't even know, you
know, what we were able to accomplish,
the things that we've been able to do,
what does it look like to
have those kinds of group
economics and those examples,
cuz they've been destroyed.
- Yeah.
- And we've kind of just moved on.
So history, we need to really focus
on history in our schools because that's,
I mean, that's the hardest thing about
not knowing where to go is we really
don't even understand where we came from.
- You said something that I think is very important,
um, and that is the core of a
lot of these clips and things
that we see on social media, right?
Which is what exactly is racism.
Because, for example, when you saw
like, you know, Amy Cooper call the
cops and, like, threaten essentially
this Black man's existence, a lot of
people were like, “She's not racist.”
Even she came out and
was like, “I'm not racist.”
Which begs the question of, like, then
what do you think racism is?
- Well, yeah.
- And I do think a lot of white
people do think racism is explicit.
- Yup.
- When really a lot of racism is
microaggression that’s maybe a
little bit more covert. Like, racism
doesn't just exist in somebody
looking at you and saying, “I don't
like you because you're Black.”
That is a very small level of
what it means to be racist.
So I'm curious, can you tell me
about a time that maybe you have
experienced that more covert racism—
I know there's tons, right?—
but some times that you could pinpoint?
- Uh...I mean, there's plenty.
There are plenty of times.
I don't like to throw around the
word “racism” loosely because I know,
to your point,
a lot of, the person I'm talking
to, this white person, probably
doesn’t even understand what
I'm talking about when I say, “OK,
that was racist” or “You're racist.”
So, you know, for me, I think every
Black person has had, you know, something.
Like, I've been pulled over
because officers in my hometown
thought I was my brother, and they
harass my brother all the time, you know, but it's
not until they know that I'm like, “My
head coach in high school was a Sergeant.”
So as long as I name-drop him,
I'm lucky enough to have that
kind of association, that I know—
they know I have somebody to, to
protect, you know, me. But I think,
you know, when it comes to racism,
people have to understand that
it's, it has nothing to do with—
it can deal with hate, but you don't have
to hate people in order to be racist.
Race has everything to do with your
prejudices and the ability to exercise
some type of power, which is why you
hear a lot of Black people say Black
people can't be racist.
- Right. Because it's about power.
- Because it has everything to do with
power. That white woman in the park
who's able to, to call—the reason
she's calling the police and saying “A
Black man has threatened me” is because
she knows that the system is set up
in order to react to that situation.
If a white woman calls
and says that “A Black man is
threatening me,”
she knows the type of response that is
going to be given. History has shown that
from all the way from Emmett Till to,
to Tulsa being torn down because of
allegedly a white woman being assaulted
in an elevator, the same thing with
Rosewood, same thing with the Red Summer
of 1919—every single time, if you
can—I think it’s well-known that
white women are protected by any
means in this, in this country.
And so while you don't have to be racist
or hate Black people, you can still
utilize a racist system to your benefit
if you ever get scared or
ever just get in a bad mood.
And we've seen, you know, white
women really abusing that
system because they know
the system is rigged.
They might not, you know, participate in it,
and they might not contribute to it,
but when they want to tap into it,
they know it’s there,
and they've been using it.
And I think that is where
the racism comes into.
- There's this author whose
name is Kiese Laymon.
He's fantastic.
And he wrote an autobiography, or
really a memoir, and it's called Heavy.
And in it, he says that the term
“white privilege” that we use
is probably it should be called
“white power” because it's about this
power that white people have that
enables them to move through life.
- Yup.
- But calling it privilege almost,
like, minimizes what it actually is.
It's something that you have that I
don't, which in turn gives you power
over me and over a lot of things.
- Right. Yeah. Yeah.
- And I think that there probably is some,
some truth to that.
I think the reason that it’s never going
to be the popular term is because “white
power” also has a different definition,
which is maybe a bit elevated than
exchanging it for the word “privilege.”
- Yeah.
- But I do think if people realized
that racism, like you said, isn't
just hate—it's about power and the
way that you harness that over other
Individuals that maybe don't look
like you—there'd be a much better
understanding of how we can navigate
kind of away from that, that ideal.
- I like that idea cuz I feel like when you
talk about privilege, like,
that's a passive term, right?
- Mhmm.
- Like, I can choose whether I want to
exercise the privilege or not, but
when we talk about it, like, “Hey, no,
you have, you have this power,”
like, that is an active word.
Like, you can—and this is why
we talk about being an ally—
we don't want you to, to deny
that you have white privilege.
We don't want you to ignore your
privilege. We want you to use it.
Like, you have the power.
So we want you to either
relinquish that power to,
to elevate somebody who's Black or, you
know, or in that regard, or use that power
to break down these systems because you
can have more power, more leverage, more
reach than a lot of your Black peers.
And I think, you know,
it is not a, it is not a crime or
an indictment against white people
to acknowledge that you have a power
or privilege. You didn't create it.
Like, it was given to you.
In this point in time,
it's, it's what do you do with it.
You know, are you using that to
advance us as a people or
to keep us in a status quo?
And I think that's kind of that—it's
a responsibility. And it's hard
for people to take that on, especially,
like, as fast as this movement has kind
of come and people have had to kind
of process this, but it's gonna
come down to, if we want to be better
as a country, it’s going to come down
to white people who have power and
who have this privilege using it to
change us because we're the minority.
We don't have enough votes, voices to
do it completely on our own.
And it's going to come down to those
allies using their power and privilege to assist.
- And one of the reasons I asked
that question off top is because,
you know, that moment where you
realize being Black is different
is very commonly referred
to as an awakening.
And I think a lot of Black
people are actually having
that awakening in this moment,
and—which seems crazy.
- That is crazy.
- But I can tell from some of these, like,
statements and, like, things people are
saying that this is their awakening moment.
Am I alone in feeling that way?
Or have you felt that way at all?
- I wouldn't say it's an awakening. It would
be hard for me to really, to really—
and it could be true—but it would be
hard for me to fathom,
just in my own experience and
background, that Black people, you know,
at this moment, this is the first time
they’ve recognized that their Blackness
means something in this country.
Everything about our culture
is copied, is replicated.
And hell don't have a guard,
but we are demonized for it.
Like, we have been completely detached
from our, you know, heritage and Africa and
all of our traditions. We literally
integrated ourselves into a Western
world, and we've made it our own.
We created, you know, great things out
of, you know, this assimilating, but
for whatever reason, when you still have
that, that racism and prejudice still
around, like, you're constantly butting
your head against like, well, like, “What
is it?” Like, “What else do we have to do
in order to be seen as, as true people?”
And I think that, that we're at that
boiling point where people are tired,
tired of assimilating, and you’re starting to
see more people, you know, look back into
their heritage, look back into history
and really try to find themselves because
for us, trying to fit in completely into
this Western kind of mentality really
hasn't played out to our benefit.
- I saw, I mean, obviously we know
that there has been awakening for
a number of different NFL players.
I think Drew Brees kind
of took the forefront
of that when he was, um, getting some heat—
rightfully so—for the statement
he didn't make when he was asked
about the protests, and you also
became a part of that story because
you posted a very powerful video
talking about the
situation on your Instagram.
- Drew Brees
if you don't understand how hurtful,
how insensitive your comments are
you are part of the problem.
- And, I mean, in the video, it was
emotional, and you were crying.
And I know tears can be the manifestation
of a lot of different things.
Like, what did the tears
represent for you in that video?
Like, what emotions were those tears?
- Well, honestly, I think, you know, one
thing that, that our—and it's the only reason
that I posted the video is cuz I don't like
being emotional in front of people. Like, that’s
not what I’m comfortable doing, but I think
people have to understand how
much Black people carry just
kind of underneath their skin.
Like, just on a day-to-day basis, the things
that we put up with that we don't
say, the things that we see constantly
and we internalize, but, you know, try
to have to go into a corporate, you
know, workplace and still get along,
or have to go into these spaces that
aren't for us—we aren't represented,
you know—and make people feel
comfortable with who we are all the time.
And then for, you know, all of the things
to kind of come to fruition as they have,
you know, in the last month
to—that was kind of like, it
was hurtful because this is, these
are people who you think, you know,
see you for who you are and kind of
see your struggles and recognize it.
And it's, it was like, you know,
frustrating because I'm like, if, if
the people closest to me don't know
what it feels like for me to
be in this skin, then, all right,
we've got a long way to go.
And I think it's important.
It was important for not only
Drew, but everybody who's having
these, these tough conversations to
understand that these things hurt.
And they've been along—
around for a long time.
A lot of the stuff we internalize.
It’s not just that it happened to
George Floyd in Minnesota.
Like, when we see that constantly,
I see my younger brothers.
I see my cousins, my uncles, my dad.
Like, that could easily be—
so when we see ourselves, like,
dying, we see that, that trauma,
and it does something to you.
And I don't think that, you know,
a lot of guys are aware of kind of
that burden that people carry around, and
we do it, and we still keep a smile on our
face, and we still create beautiful things.
We still have culture and
we smile, but it's tough.
And I think the number one thing
you've heard people say in the
last month is like, “We’re tired.”
And I think that's really what that
was, just like, “I’m exhausted by holding this
weight that I didn't even put on myself.” You know?
- Yeah.
- So I think that’s what it is.
- Cuz I do think a lot of people
saw the emotion and was like, “He's so sad.”
And I was like, “No, I
think he's probably angry
and hurt.” It's not like a sadness as much
as it is, like everything that, that has
come with it, you know? It's just been
an accumulation kind of of everything.
Do you think Drew
now has a better grasp?
- I do.
I mean, yeah, I do.
And I think, you know,
I think it came in, in phases.
I honestly don't think he
really, you know, necessarily
knew what he wasn't saying.
And I, and I tried to tell
him, it's like, “Your
thoughts on the flag are yours.
You are open to that opinion.
I have no problem with that opinion.”
I was like, “Nobody's hurt because
of how you feel about the flag.
We actually know that about you and expect
that from you. But it's more about, you
know, acknowledging what it may,
what it may mean to me or
what it may not mean to me.
Or what it—not even about the flag, just
about the entire demonstration in
general, what that's about. Acknowledging
that, like, pain or that gripe
or grievance that I have is,
is really what it comes down to.”
And I think obviously with all
of the backlash, with him talking,
you know, to a lot of the guys that
he's been closest with and the guys
that he's played with, you know, over his long
career—he reached out to a lot
of us, me included, and, and I think
guys being able to tell somebody
like Drew Brees the truth, that,
like, “Your words hurt because of this,”
like, this was, you know, I think that that
helped him really, one, realize how deep
it was for his teammates and for other
people that didn't share his experience.
And I think, you know, he understands that
sometimes, you know, there's opportunity
for you to really just listen and, and
be a lot more careful, especially as
polarized as our country is, you
know, when leaders come out and
speak, you have different factions
trying to attach themselves to,
like, these figureheads, right?
Which we saw Trump try to jump
right on Drew's comments.
And I'm glad that, that Drew
stood up to Trump and said, “No.”
- Me too. [Laughing] Yeah.
- That was an important step.
And I think that that shows
that he at least understands
that, one, there's things
for him to learn, but, two,
like, this,
these aren't made-up stories.
People have been
complaining for centuries
that there is a real issue
here, and it's time for us
to really, truly understand the depths of it.
- The Drew Brees video ended up being
pretty necessary in a lot of ways.
Cuz it kind of served as a
catalyst for some other things.
Obviously we saw a lot of NFL stars come
together and make the video to Roger Goodell.
You know, with Michael Thomas, Saquon
Barkley, Odell, everybody joining
that video, and Roger Goodell then
responded with a video as well.
Do you feel like that was a genuine move,
on the NFL’s part?
- I think, you know, even if it was,
and I've said this before, until
they address the Colin Kaepernick
thing, nobody's really going to,
like, acknowledge the efforts they
put forth. You know, they've, they’ve
given money in the past.
They’ve created entire
“Inspire Change” things. You know, coming out
with statements, you know, don't matter.
What players really want to see is,
like, how are you going to address
Colin Kaepernick
now that you had this awakening of, you
know, how you should have done better,
and then, two, like, what does that look like?
Not only with just cutting checks
for charities, but what does it look
like within your hiring practices?
There's, like, four Black
coaches and two Black GMs.
When are you going to start
adding leadership into
your, you know, front offices?
That's what people want to see.
The statements, really, you
know, don't matter.
And I think the more and more we kind
of get caught up in all of these statements,
it's, like, the less time we actually
spend as athletes, too, talking about
the actual, like, issues and what we
need to be drawing attention to.
So I think it's one
of those things that it’s—
I'd rather them not make statements
because when they do the whole country
focuses back on the NFL, what they're
doing, when in reality, we need to be
pushing our focus to legislation, to this,
to getting people registered to vote
in this election that's coming up.
Like, there are so many things
that we need to be focused on.
And I think every time
the NFL chimes in on, you
know, what's happening, it just
leads to more questions and more
scrutiny and more distraction.
- Yeah, I mean, I will say, I think it's a
double-edged sword in a lot of ways, right?
Because I agree and I commend you on
how, whenever these things happen, you're
like, “OK, what's the actionable item?”
That's always your thing.
What can I do to help?
What can I do to, you know, for the
advancement of Black people? We have
talked at length, you know, with,
like, things that you can actually do.
And I think that's great,
and it's important.
And it's probably what is the most
important. But on the other side, one of
the main things for me throughout this
time has been that places and people need
to acknowledge things that they have done.
Cuz acknowledgement, I think, is a big
part of healing for a lot of people.
And for me, that is what has been lacking
for the NFL, is the acknowledgement,
because, and correct me if I'm wrong,
I think the NFL has played
a role in perpetuating
either Black people staying stagnant or
in perpetuating some racist ideologies.
I think it's important for them to
have to say something about that.
- Yeah. I think, I think if you were looking
at, if you wanted to measure them
on the diversity in their hiring
practices, outside of the players,
I would say that there's definitely
a need for more diversity, and that
could be perpetuating a racist kind
of, you know, organization. Not that
they, I don't think they would consider
themselves racist, but if you divide
them up by race, it's telling.
I think if you look at, um, you
know, obviously Colin Kaepernick
and what he did and what that in context
now, like, you have police officers,
people taking knees all over the
world, because it stood for something,
um, I think that they contributed in,
um, or, or allowed that message
to be muddied up, and that
hurt kind of that movement.
And I think they just, they
just flat-out owe Kaepernick an apology.
That's the acknowledgement
I think that needs to happen.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- Cuz, you know, that's really
what everybody wants to hear.
The rest of it is cool.
Everybody's having an awakening.
I don't think anybody even, like, holds you
to that, but they had an opportunity to
really be out in front and be proactive.
And that's the most unfortunate
thing I think about our league
and leadership in our leagues.
We haven't really been very proactive
when it comes to things that ail the
Black community, or really not even
the Black community, just in general.
We were late on domestic violence.
We were late with even the
concussion stuff. They were hiding things.
And so for us, I think until
you change up or add some
diversity to your leadership,
you won't have a diversity of perspective.
You'll always be reacting to, especially
in the Black community, because you
don't have any Black representation
in leadership and the ability
to, you know, have a voice at the
table outside of your players.
And I think that's really the most
telling thing is how do you add
diversity and Black people to your
leadership to address, you know, the issues that are plaguing
the communities of 70 percent of your players?
- Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Um, couple more for you.
Obviously, you know, I think that
right now we're being fed, you know, a
lot of images and videos that are about
trauma that Black people see and withhold.
And I think what's getting
lost is that, you know, there
is so much joy in being Black.
So I want you to tell me this time, kind of,
what do you love about being Black?
Cuz I think that that's
equally as important.
- Yeah. I think, man, Black people are
so resourceful, creative—like, you
know, for us to have so much, uh,
you know, trauma, to feel oppressed
and all these things that we have,
out of those same, you know,
places have come, you know, things
that have changed the world, come the
visions that have changed the world.
Hip-hop and all of the dances that
spread around the world start in our
neighborhoods; our art, our music, like,
all of those things; the joy and love
that we see within Black families, Black
homes, Black communities; the way that we
interact with each other that other
people sometimes don't understand is,
it's something that makes us beautiful.
And I love it,
you know, personally. And I think,
you know, for a long time, and even
still now, when you try to celebrate,
like, your Blackness and be
proud of your Blackness,
sometimes people take that as being, you
know, anti-white or anti-everybody else.
And it's like, no, we
have to understand that
Black people and our image, how we've
been depicted for, since we stepped
foot into this country, has always
made us, you know, depicted us
as less than people. Literally in the
Constitution we’re less than a man.
And so here we are now in 2020, having to
purposely affirm ourselves, having to
lift up those things that are beautiful about
us, lift up each other and celebrate
our culture, our history, our skin, our
hair, our dance, everything about it because
we know wholeheartedly that the world
will tell us that those things, you
know, are not great, are not beautiful.
And I think we went through
really a couple generations that
tried to do everything, you know, white.
Tried to change their hair,
change their skin color.
And I think there's, you know, this
resurgence of this pride in who we are.
And I think that is the
essence of being Black.
Is it to be able to maintain
your joy and be able to create
great things, to be able to thrive and have joy, regardless of
what the circumstances are around you.
- Yeah, for sure.
I think we have a gift to
thrive despite our surroundings.
And I think that that's super important,
and that shouldn't get lost on anybody.
I always say, it's like, at the end of the
day, every good quality about myself,
I feel like I owe to being Black.
And regardless of the, you know, injustice
that we face or the hate that we may face,
I would never want to be anything else.
And I truly mean that.
I don't know what life is without
Blackness being at my core.
And I try to, like, implore people
throughout this time to, like, know
that and remember that because it's so
easy to feel like maybe life could
have been easier if it was this or
that, but, like, you'd be so different.
And there's just so many positives.
And so much strength comes from it.
And I think, I think that's really
important to say as often as we can
that, yes, we are these things, but
we're other things too and to not
be too, um, too caught up in that.
So those words are great.
So I'm ending all of these with
the same question. Just like
I begin with the same one, I'm
ending with the same as well.
So words, of course, mean
different things to different people.
How do you define "America"?
- I think that there's, it's
changed over the years.
Um...um.
I think I see America as a place
that I'm constantly trying to make home.
Like, that's, that's how I feel
about it, is that, you know, this,
uh. I'm obviously American.
This is where I live.
This is the country I
affiliate with. This is where I
pay taxes. But something about it
has not quite felt like,
you know, it's made for me.
And I think a lot of Black
people can say that they have been
trying to make this place ours, to,
you know, to make sure that we fight
for the same rights as everybody else
cuz we built this country. But
that is not necessarily reality.
And so, it's home by definition,
but I'm constantly trying to make
it my home, if that makes any sense.
- Yeah.
A place I'm always trying
to make home, for sure.
Thank you, Malcolm.
- Thank you.